it's hard to foster an innovative
culture because the activities of
executing the business that you already
have in manufacturing with very high
levels of quality satisfying customers
needs are entailed being very deliberate
and repetitive in order to be successful
innovation is is not quite as
predictable especially if you're
developing an innovation that would
appeal to a different set of customers
than the ones that you're currently
serving and as a consequence innovations
that help you do a better job serving
your existing customers are rarely a
problem its innovations that target a
new set of customers with something that
is simpler and more convenient those are
the ones that you have trouble with
because it just makes no sense to the
logic of the organization to spend money
developing products that your customers
can't use
what you have to do is just as you're
walking around the world keep your eyes
out for where are they doing something
in a location that is inconvenient and
expensive and difficult where I could
bring a technology to it that would
enable it to be done in a much simpler
location with greater convenience at
lower cost for where are they doing
something in a centralized location
where I could decentralize it
where is there a population of people
who cannot now afford something where my
technology would enable it to be enable
them to afford it a great opportunity
actually is in a good illustration that
this is in green energy there are no non
consumers of energy in the United States
and Europe basically everybody has
access to very reliable cost-effective
power over the electrical grid or
gasoline through the the petroleum
industry and what that means is
disruptive innovations are unlikely ever
to to take root here ultimately they may
penetrate this market but they won't
take root here where they take root is
amongst the two billion people in Asia
and Africa who don't yet have
electricity and they're the ones who
would be who really need to be given a
product that is simple affordable
convenient where everybody could
generate the electricity of their homes
rather than have to go through the cost
of building the electrical grid and then
in that context the technology gets
better and better until ultimately it
can be used in North America and Europe
that's just a lil astray ssin you got to
look for a population that can't afford
it doesn't have access to it simplify
the technology so that they can and
that's the disruption that we're talking